the Levee breach on the Pajaro river is
widening growing to more than 120 meters
since Friday that's ominous for the town
of Pajaro Downstream as more storms Bear
Down on the farming Community this week
paharo's 1700 residents were told to
evacuate during a brief moment of
sunshine on Tuesday families looked
across the river toured their empty
homes blocked by a bridge now only
accessible to emergency workers how's
your
uh so far we don't know we're not
allowed to go in or anything like that
but it's actually pretty frustrating not
knowing the county of Monterey has
performed more than 170 high water
rescues as a result of this flood using
utility vehicles army vehicles to rescue
people who are stranded within their
homes or their vehicles but not everyone
has agreed to leave the struggle is like
them finding food and not being able to
cross the bridge to go get their food
that's what worries them the most
um some people don't even have where to
go to many also have nowhere to work
this region calls itself the salad bowl
of the world producing fruits and
vegetables by immigrant Farm Workers now
they face much of the suffering
there's no work I can't pay the rent I
have a family of four to support
these storms are the result of
atmospheric Rivers long currents of
moisture in the air that cause rain and
snowfall California has experienced no
less than 10 such once rare phenomena
since January an impact of climate
change and a probable Trend into the
future
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Pajaro
California